From rare strains of Kryptonite to the Martian
Manhunter's imaginary friend, to a Gotham
City franchise opening up a new branch, here
are the Supergirl Easter eggs that were definitely
put there for the diehards.
Since its debut in 2015, Supergirl has found
an audience by focusing on a more accessible
version of the DC Universe that's easy for
casual viewers to get a handle on.
After all, everybody knows Superman, right?
Here's his cousin, she's got the same powers,
does the same stuff, is a similarly good and
charming person, let's go have adventures,
preferably involving ice cream!
“YES!”
With that in mind, it might be surprising
to learn that one of the show's most deep-cut
references comes from one of the very first
things we learn about the show: its setting.
It's easy to think that Kara Danvers' adopted
hometown of National City has a standard issue
generic name like most of the other fictional
towns in the DC Universe.
After all, Gotham is just an old nickname
for New York, and Metropolis is literally
just a word that means "big city."
Unlike those, however, National City doesn't
have its roots in comics.
It was created for the show, and its name
has a meaning that goes a little deeper than
just being a city within a nation, which many,
if not most, cities are.
Instead, National City is a reference to Supergirl's
publisher.
No, not Cat Grant, but DC Comics.
The fact that "DC" stands for "Detective Comics"
is pretty well-known meaning that yes, "DC
Comics" is actually "Detective Comics Comics"
but fewer people know that this wasn't actually
the company's official name until the late
'70s.
Before that, they were National Periodical
Publications.
It's nice nod to the character's history,
since National was still the company's name
when Supergirl was introduced in 1959, but
it's pretty obscure.
If only there was some major city they could've
used with some connection to the letters "D.C."
In "Shelter From the Storm," the 18th episode
of Supergirl's third season, Kara, Alex, Mon-El,
and Reign all take a trip to Lex Luthor's
mansion.
As you might expect, his interior decorating
tastes mostly lean towards deathtraps meant
to kill Superman, but it's not all wall-mounted
machine guns and chunks of Kryptonite.
Once the big brawl starts up downstairs, we
get a pretty good look at his art collection
when Supergirl and Reign start knocking each
other through paintings.
Fortunately, Lex kept one important piece
of art upstairs, out of harm's way: Saint
Michael Vanquishing Satan, by Raphael.
In real life, it's a priceless work of art
that hangs in the Louvre, and considering
that it's literally a painting of good triumphing
over evil, it seems like an odd choice for
Lex Luthor.
There is, however, a reason for it to be there,
and it has nothing to do with Lex's taste
in art at least, not on the show.
Instead, it's a callback to Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice, where Lex has a version of
the same scene hanging in his office.
It is, however, a different piece of art.
The movie used a more dramatic version by
Gustav Doré called "The Fall of the Rebel
Angels," which Lex hangs it upside down to
depict Satan descending from the sky in a
pretty un-subtle metaphor about his feelings
for Superman.
Still, it's a depiction of the same scene.
Turns out Lex's tastes are pretty consistent,
no matter what universe he's in.
Most people are familiar with Kryptonite,
and most comic book fans are aware that the
familiar Green K is only one of several types
that have shown up in comics through the years.
Supergirl has tapped into this long tradition,
too, digging up Blue, Red, and even "Synthetic"
Kryptonite, all of which have their origins
in the comics.
In the finale of season 2, however, the show
busts out a pretty obscure one: Silver Kryptonite,
which first appeared in 1963's Superman's
Pal Jimmy Olsen #70.
Well, except that it didn't, because it wasn't
actually real.
Well, even less real than all the other stuff.
In "The Secret of the Silver Kryptonite,"
Jimmy tricked Superman into being worried
about a strange new strain with unknown effects,
only for it to turn out as a hoax.
It was silver for Superman's silver anniversary
— the story was meant to mark 25 years since
the Man of Steel's debut in 1938.
The version we see on Supergirl, however,
is very real, or at least as real as regular
green Kryptonite, and can cause paranoia and
hallucinations.
In Kara's case, that means that her cousin
Clark attacks her because he thinks she's
General Zod, but this version has a precedent,
too.
It's actually a reference to the CW's previous
long-running Super-show, Smallville, where
it showed up in season 5 with a similar effect
on that show's version of Clark Kent.
You'd expect Supergirl to have plenty of references
to the old Richard Donner and Christopher
Reeve Superman movies that made audiences
believe a man could fly.
What you might not have expected was that
they'd build huge plot points around elements
lifted from the Supergirl movie that spun
off of them.
Which, at the time, convinced audiences to
stay at home instead of going to see it.
Kara's 1984 cinematic outing is often forgotten
by fans.
Despite the fact that star Helen Slater made
a fantastic Supergirl in her own right, and
would wind up playing Kara's adoptive mom
on the TV show, the movie was honestly not
very good.
The inconsistent, confusing plot was largely
built around a Kryptonian McGuffin called
the Omegahedron, which had the vague power
to do... well, whatever the plot required,
really.
Chasing it down was what led Supergirl to
Earth, and the bad guys mainly wanted to use
it for evil magic spells, which, you know,
sure, whatever.
Cut to 35 years later, and the show brings
in the Omegahedron as a major plot device
in its first season.
Not only was it used by Non to rebuild Indigo,
making her an even more formidable threat,
it was also the power source for Myriad, the
mind-control device that Supergirl faced off
against in the last two episodes of the first
season.
Like the movie, the show kept the limits of
the Omegahedron's abilities pretty vague,
but they did identify it as a Kryptonian power
source, explaining why Myriad was so powerful
that it could even affect Superman.
Supergirl is obviously chock full of ideas
and elements pulled from the Superman comics,
and with Lynda Carter appearing as President
Marsdin, there are more than a few nods to
Wonder Woman, too.
As far as the rest of the DC Universe goes,
however, you might be surprised to learn that
the show's most prominent pull from Gotham
City has very little to do with the Dark Knight.
Instead, it comes from the pages of Hitman.
Created by Garth Ennis and John McCrea, Tommy
Monaghan originally appeared as part of the
1993 Bloodlines event, in which every DC Comic
of the time introduced a brand new hero or
villain to the universe.
If you're wondering why you've never heard
of, say, Shadowstryke, Razorsharp, or Ballistic,
it's because Tommy, a working-class hitman
for hire whose powers gave him a headache
when he tried to use them, was the only one
who was any good.
For some reason, Gunfire, the man who could
turn anything into a gun, didn't click with
audiences.
What does this have to do with Supergirl?
Well, Tommy was from a neighborhood in Gotham
City called the Cauldron, where his main hangout
was a bar called Noonan's.
If you're a fan of Supergirl, you might recognize
that as the name of the restaurant where Kara
worked as a waitress before being hired by
Cat Grant.
The show's brightly lit, family friendly dining
establishment is a far cry from a dive bar
frequented by hired killers with a literal
demon named Baytor as a bartender, but when
it comes to naming places on a superhero show,
there's no such thing as coincidence.
Incidentally, this one actually has a reference
within a reference: one of the most memorable
scenes set in Supergirl's version of Noonan's
comes from the season 1 episode "Falling."
When Kara is exposed to Red Kryptonite and
briefly becomes a jerk, she flicks peanuts
at a shelf of bottles behind the bar, shattering
them.
If you're a super-cinephile, you'll recognize
that as a direct recreation of a scene from
Superman III.
One of the great things about a show like
Supergirl is that with so much time to work
with over the course of several seasons and
so much history for one of the best characters
in comics, the creators can really dig back
into the past and reintroduce forgotten elements
of a character.
Take, for instance, Rick Malverne.
"Malverne.
Why does that sound so familiar?"
“Because he grew up in Midvale."
Even on the show, he's not the most prominent
character; only one appearance outside of
a flashback, in season 2's "Alex."
There, he's depicted as a childhood friend
of Kara's who learned her secret back in their
school days, but kept it to himself until
he was an adult, using that knowledge to kidnap
Alex and manipulate Supergirl into breaking
his father out of prison.
Unless you've read a bunch of Supergirl comics
from 50 years ago, you might've missed that
Rick is actually from the comics, although
he's a very different character there.
On the page, Dick Malverne, who got a name
change for obvious reasons, was Supergirl's
version of Lois Lane or Lana Lang.
He was the childhood friend who suspected
Supergirl's secret identity and kept trying
to get her to reveal it, which in Dick's case
once escalated into literally faking his own
death.
Like his TV counterpart, it was later revealed
that Dick had always known Supergirl's identity
for a fact, and his elaborate plans were his
way of dunking on the girl he had a crush
on.
Truly, a character who lives up to his name.
There are plenty of references to comics to
be found in dialogue throughout Supergirl,
but on the off chance that you haven't noticed,
there's also a reference in most of the episode
titles throughout the series.
In Season 2, we got one that was a nesting
doll of deep-cut comics references: "Supergirl
Lives."
There was once a movie in development with
the same title, And yes: it's that Superman
movie.
The one that Tim Burton was going to make,
with Nicolas Cage in a glorious mullet wig
and that amazingly weird Batman & Robin-style
muscle suit.
All things considered, it's probably a good
thing that movie never happened.
There's another layer to the reference, though.
"Supergirl Lives" was directed by podcaster,
filmmaker, and occasional comic book writer
Kevin Smith, who wrote the screenplay for
Superman Lives and has frequently spoken about
the experience.
There are even a couple of references to his
unproduced screenplay in the episode, if you're
sharp and nerdy enough to catch them.
"It's Thanagarian snarebeast."
It won't blow anybody's mind to learn that
most of the characters we see on Supergirl,
especially the ones who run around in costumes,
are from the comics.
Guardian?
He's from the comics, although he's never
been Jimmy Olsen under the mask.
Indigo, the evil robot?
She's from the comics, too!
The Martian Manhunter?
That dude's been a member of the Justice League
since 1961, you know he's from the comics!
Here's one that might actually surprise you,
though.
Remember Zook, the imaginary friend that J'onn
mentions having when he was a kid back on
Mars?
"What was his name?"
"Zook."
Yeah, that is also from the comics.
No, really.
In the Silver Age, there was a very weird
trend of superheroes having weird little magical
imps showing up in their stories to cause
wacky troubles.
Obviously, the most famous, and the one who
got the whole trend started, is Superman's
fifth-dimensional foe Mr. Mxyzptlk, who appeared
on Supergirl in season 2, and you've probably
heard of Bat-Mite, the Caped Crusader's biggest
fan.
Those are just the well-known tips of the
inter-dimensional iceberg, though.
Aquaman was annoyed by a sprite named Qwisp,
who had a twin brother named Quink.
The Flash even had one, Mopee, a "guardian
angel" who was revealed to have been completely
responsible for Barry Allen getting his powers
in a story that fans hated so much that it
was immediately retconned out of existence.
Zook, on the other hand, managed to rack up
18 appearances in the Silver Age as a full-on
sidekick before being shuffled off into the
limbo of things we don't talk about… unless
it's on Supergirl.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.